son parte de la élite del atletismo de
velocidad de sudamérica ahora reunidos
en bogotá para un entrenamiento con
altura del alexander gilmar jennifer
diego antoni y lina integran un proyecto
de colombia que dirige el experimentado
entrenador cubano nelson gutiérrez con
la ilusión de brillar en el relevo
masculino y mixto en los juegos de tokio
queremos seguir soñando con una medalla
la idea es esa o sea no lo vamos a
cambiar realmente vemos vamos a ver cómo
se va desarrollando toda la preparación
hoy por hoy ya podemos trabajar ya
tenemos otra otra esperanza en el
trabajo sostenido anthony zambrano
sorprendió el mundo el año pasado con
una plata en el mundial de atletismo de
doha en los 400 metros planos el equipo
terminó en cuarta plaza un gran momento
que se congeló con el aplazamiento de
los juegos ya yo que venía de hacer
segundo en un mundial venía con mucha
ansiedad muchas ganas de ser finalista
olímpico pero además hemos advertido
como que la ilusión ni nada eso me ha
sido como que más fuerte porque yo
siento que eso fue como con una barrera
como un obstáculo
la pandemia ha marcado su preparación
unos pudieron ir a entrenar un tiempo
lisboa otros recibían instrucciones de
manera virtual ahora este año termina
con una aparente normalidad este año
digamos que pese a lo duro ha sido más
bien para enseñarnos y nos ha permitido
enfocarnos en lo que realmente queremos
bueno se nos dio la posibilidad de estar
en europa
entrenando y ya bueno ahora estamos aquí
continuando la preparación y con mucha
ilusión ha sido muy difícil porque creo
que cada uno de nosotros tenía una meta
tenía como que su su visión y su
ambición de mejorar en lo personal se
alejó un poco nuestro sueño pero sí
intacto
compiten en una categoría que no es una
especialidad de la región y ante unos
rivales de europa y norteamérica que han
tenido más facilidades para entrenar en
la pandemia pero el camino a tokio aún
no ha terminado